i'm going on kind of a tangent but uh
this will hopefully be of some value to
people
do i do chapter three has
spammed my study what is this
because i pasted url i meant to paste a
pgn
this was 2018 it was the same tournament
it was in melbourne australia
the australasian masters invitational
event
um i got to this position
just showing the final or finale to the
game
i was white and i played my next move
thinking i was winning
[Music]
and this is the worst move i've ever
played
so maybe i'll give this as a puzzle to
chat
white to move what should white play
there is actually um
there is like a clear best move or two
moves that are like clearly best
but white to move and
not play what i played easy deezy asking
if i'm married
not that i know of okay most people
have an idea of what's happening here
we'll start with the best moves
only a few people saying the best moves
so white's actually in a bit of trouble
here black's threatening to
play queen f2 in mate like if it's box
move queen f2 and white's just losing
because then there's no good way to stop
queen g2
[Music]
so everyone that wants to take on b6 um
this loses instantly the move i played
wasn't much better
so the only two moves which kind of deal
with this threat
are either queen d7
because this attacks the bishop has some
idea of queen f5
i think it's approximately equal after
queen d7
or queen a6 to then respond to queen f2
with queen e2
so in this position i had about five
minutes left and i spent about like a
minute or two calculating i was so
excited to unleash like a cool tactic i
was calculating queen
g7 king g7 i work
i win back the queen and then i get a
winning end game
um so i confidently played queen takes
g7
and like right after i played it and hit
the clock i realized
oh no my queen
because my opponent first of all like
pause for a moment
i was hoping my appointment would resign
but then my opponents
kind of looked at me and it wasn't a
good type of look
i think my opponent like looked at me
and just felt sorry for me
and i realized my night's pinned
this move is not legal so then i just
resigned
it was so sad i just gave away my queen
for nothing
it was so painful to do this in like an
over the board game too
um and there's a big rating differential
so
[Music]
uh what to do that's life